the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
welcome back so we're now moving to a
new chapter which is gonna have a little
more of a statistical flavor when it
comes to designing methods right because
if you think about it okay
some of you have probably attempted
problem number 2 in the problem set then
you realize that maximum likelihood
estimators does not give you super
trivial estimators right I mean when you
have an n theta theta then you know the
thing you get is not something you could
have guessed before you actually
attempted to solve that problem and so
in a way we've seen already
sophisticated methods however in many
instances the maximum likelihood
estimator was just an average and in a
way even if we had this confirmation for
maximum likelihood that indeed that was
the estimator that maximum likelihood
would spit out and there our intuition
was therefore pretty good most of the
statistical analysis or use of the
central limit theorem all these things
actually did not come in the building of
the estimator in the design of the
estimator but really in the analysis of
the estimator and you could say well you
know if I know already that the best
estimator is the average I'm just gonna
use the average I don't have to
basically quantify how good it is I just
know it's the best I can do when we're
going to talk about tests and that we're
gonna talk about parametric hypothesis
testing so you should view this sentence
as parametric means well it's about a
parameter like we did before and I
populace testing is on the same level as
estimation and on the same level as
estimator will be the word test ok and
when we're going to devise a test we're
gonna actually need to understand random
fluctuations that arise from the central
limit theorem better ok it's not just
gonna be in the analysis it's also going
to be in the design and everything we've
been doing before in understanding the
behavior of
the manor is actually going to come in
and be extremely useful in the actual
design of tests okay so as an example I
want to talk to you about some real data
I will I will not study this data but
this data actually exists you can find
it on our and so it's the data from the
so called credit union cherry blossom
run which is a ten mount race takes
place every year in DC seems that some
of the years are pretty nice 2009 there
were about fifteen thousand participants
pretty big race and the average running
time was one of three point five minutes
all right so about an hour and a half a
little bit more and so you can ask your
following question right this is actual
data right 103.5 actually averaged the
running time for all of fifteen thousand
now this in practice might not be
something very suitable and you might
want to just sample a few runners and
try to understand how they're behaving
every year without having to collect the
entire data set and so you could ask the
question well let's say my budget is to
ask for maybe ten runners what the
running time was I still want to be able
to determine whether they were running
faster in 2012 than in 2009 why do I put
2012 and not 2016 well because the data
set for 2012 is also available and so if
you were interested and you know how to
use R just go and have fun with it so so
to answer this question what we do is we
select n runners right so n is a
moderate number that's more manageable
than 15,000 from the 2012 race at random
that's where the random fair ball is
gonna come from right that's where we
actually inject randomness in our
problem and we're gonna denote this guys
by we're going to denote so remember
this is an experiment so really in a way
the runners are the Omegas and I'm
interested in measurements on those guys
so this is how I have a random variable
and this random variable here is
measuring their running time okay if you
look at the data set you have all sorts
of random variables you could measure
about those random runners country of
origin I don't know height age a bunch
of things okay here the random variable
of entry
being the running time okay everybody
understand what the process is okay so
now I'm gonna have to make some modeling
assumptions and here I'm actually pretty
lucky I actually have all the data from
a past year I mean this is not data from
2012 which I also have but I don't use
but I can actually use past data to try
to understand what distribution do I
have right I mean after all running time
is gonna be rounded to something maybe I
can think of it a discrete random
variable maybe I can think of it as the
exponential random variable those are
positive numbers I can think I mean
there's many kind of running times that
could come up to mine many kind of
distributions I could think of for this
modeling part but turns out that if you
actually plot the histogram of those
running times for all 15,000 runners in
29 you actually are pretty happy to see
that it really looks like a bell-shaped
curve would suggest that this should be
a Gaussian so what you go on to do is
you estimate the mean from past
observations which was actually 103.5 as
we said used to meet the variance which
was 37 373 and you just try to
superimpose a curve with this one which
is a gaussian PDF with mean 103.5 in
variance 373 and you see that they
actually look very much alike and so
here you're pretty comfortable to see
that the running time actually is
Gaussian distribution all right so now I
know that the x1 to xn I'm gonna say
they're Gaussian okay I still need to
specify two parameters so what I want to
know is is the distribution the same
from past years right so I want to know
if the random variable that I'm looking
for if I'd say pick one say x1 does it
have the same distribution in 2012 that
it did in 20 2009 okay and so the
question is is x1 has a Gaussian
distribution with mean at 103.5 and
variance 273 is that clear
okay so this question that calls for a
yes/no answer is a hypothesis testing
problem I'm testing a hypothesis and
this is the basis of basically all of
data-driven scientific inquiry you just
ask question
you formulate a scientific hypothesis
knocking down this gene it's got a cure
melanoma is this true I'm gonna collect
I'm gonna try I'm gonna observe some
patients I'm gonna chain up down this
gene I'm gonna quit like some
measurements and I'm gonna try to answer
this yes/no answer this yes/no question
okay it's different from the question
what is the mean of the mean running
time for this year okay so so this
hypothesis testing is testing if this
hypothesis is true the hypothesis in
mathematical terms I mean in in in in
common English we just said was the
running time where runners running
faster all right anybody get formulate
these hypothesis now you go to a
statistician and he's like oh what
you're really asking me is is x1 normal
it has a Gaussian distribution with mean
less than 1 or 3.5 and variance 373
right that's really the question that
you ask in statistical terms and so if
you're asking if this was the same as
before there's many ways it could not be
the same as before there's basically
three ways it could not be the same as
before it could be the case that X 1 is
not equal to 1 an expectation to 1 of 3
point 5 so the expectation has changed
or the variance has changed or the
distribution has changed I mean who
knows maybe runners are now just you
know all running holding their hands and
it's like now a point mass at one given
point okay so you never know how what
could this change now of course if you
allow for any change you will find
change and so what you have to do is to
factor in as much knowledge as you can
make as many modeling assumptions so
that you can let the data speak about
your particular question here your
particular question is are they running
faster so you're only really asking a
question about the expectation you
really want to know if the expectation
has changed so as far as you're
concerned you're happy to make the
assumption that the rest has been
unchanged okay and so this is the
question we're asking is the expectation
now less than 103.5 because you
specifically asked whether runners were
going faster this year right they tend
to go faster
all right okay so this is the question
we're asking in mathematical terms so of
course when I did that I need to
basically fix the rest and fixing the
rest is actually part of the modeling
assumptions so I fix my variance to be
373 okay
I assume that the variance has not
changed between 2009 and 2012 now this
is an assumption it turns out it's wrong
so if you look at the data from 2012
this is not the correct assumption but
I'm just gonna make it right now for the
sake of argument okay if and also the
fact that it's Gaussian now this is
gonna be hard to violate right I mean
where that this bell-shaped curve come
from well it's just natural when you
just measure a bunch of things the
central limit theorem appears in the
small things of nature I mean you know
that's how that's the bedtime story you
get about the central limit theorem and
that's why the bell-shaped curve is
everywhere in nature is the sum of
little independent things that are going
on and this Gaussian assumption even if
I wanted to relax it there's not much as
I can do and it is pretty robust across
the years all right so the only thing
that we did not fix is the expectation
of x1 which now I want to know what it
is and since I don't know what it is I'm
gonna call it u and it's gonna be a
variable of interest all right so it's
just a number mu whatever this is I can
try to estimate it maybe using maximum
likelihood estimation probably using the
average because this is Gaussian and we
know that the maximum likelihood
estimator for a Gaussian is just the
average and now we only want to test if
mu is equal to 1 or 3.5 like it was in
2009 or on the contrary if mu is not
equal to 1 of 3.5 and more specifically
if mu is actually strictly less than 1
of 3.5 that's the question you asked now
why am I writing mu equal to 1 of 3.5
and not and or is less than 1 and 3.5
rather than equal to 13.5 not e versus
not equal to 1 over 3.5 it's because
since you asked me a more precise
question I'm gonna be able to give you a
more precise answer and so if your
question is very specific are they
running faster I'm gonna factor that in
the
what I write if you just asked me is it
the same I'm gonna have to write or is
it different than 103.5 and that's less
information about what you're looking
for okay so by making the modeling all
these modeling assumptions the fact that
the variance isn't change the fact that
it's still Gaussian have actually
reduced the number of and I put numbers
in in quotes because this is still an
infinite of them but then I'm limiting
the number of ways the hypothesis can be
violated the number of ways the number
of possible alternative realities for
this hypothesis all right
for example I'm saying there's no way
Mew can be larger than 1 or 3.5 I've
already factored that in okay it could
be but I'm actually just gonna say that
if it's larger all I'm gonna be able to
tell you is that it's not smaller I'm
not being able to tell you that it's
actually not that it's actually larger
okay so and the only way it can be
rejected now the only way I can reject
my apophysis is if access belongs to
very specific family of distributions if
it has a distribution which is Gaussian
with mean mu and variance 373 for MU
which is less than 1 or 3.5 all right so
we started with basically was x1 so
that's the reality
x1 follows n 103.5 373 okay and this is
everything else right so for example
here is X follows some exponential I
don't know point 0.1 okay this is just
another distribution here those are all
the possible distribution what we said
is we said okay first of all let's just
keep only those Gaussian distributions
right and second we said well let's look
only at the among those Gaussian
distributions let's only look at those
that
have well maybe this one should be at
the boundary say let's only look at the
gaussians here so this guy here are all
the gaussians with mean mu and variance
373 for MU less than 103.5 okay so when
you're gonna give me data I'm gonna be
able to say well am i this guy or am I
one of those guys rather than searching
through everything and the more you
search the easier for you is to find
something that fits better the data
right and so if I allow everything
possible then there's gonna be something
that just by pure randomness is actually
gonna look better for the data okay
so right so for example if I draw ten
random variables right if n is equal to
ten then and let's say they take ten
different values then it's actually more
likely that those guys come from a
discrete distribution that takes each of
this value with probability one over ten
then actually some Gaussian random
variable right that would be perfect I
can actually explain it if the ten
numbers I got were say 90 let's say I
collect three 90 95 and 102 then the
most likely distribution for those guys
is the discrete distribution that takes
three values ninety one with probability
1/3 ninety-five with probability 1/3 and
one or two with probability 1 or 2 with
probability 1/3 right that's definitely
the most likely distribution for this so
if I allowed this I would say oh no this
is not distributed according to that
it's distributed according to this very
specific distribution which is somewhere
in the realm of all possible
distributions ok so now we're just going
to try to carve out all this stuff by
making our assumptions ok so here in
this particular example just like Mickey
mental note that what we're doing is
that I actually a little birdie told me
that the reference number is one of 3.5
okay that was the thing I'm actually
look
for in practice it sexually seldom the
case that you have this reference for
yourself to think of right maybe here I
just happen to have a full data set of
all the runners of 2009 but if I really
just asked you I said where runners
faster in 2012 then in 2009 here's $10
to perform your statistical analysis
what you're probably gonna do is called
maybe 10 runners from 2012 maybe 15
runners from 2009 ask them and try to
compare their mean there's no standard
reference you would not be able to come
up with this 103.5 because these data
maybe is expensive to get or something
okay so this is really more the standard
case alright where you really compare
two things with each other but there's
no like actual ground truth number that
you're comparing it to
okay so we'll come back to that in a
second I'll tell you what the other
example looks like so let's just stick
to this example I tell you to 103.5 okay
let's try to have our intuition work the
same way we said well you know taking
averages worked well the average should
tell me about over this ten guys should
tell me what the average should be what
the mean should be so I could just say
well X bar is gonna be close to the true
mean by the law of large number so I'm
going to decide whether X bar is less
than one or three point five would
conclude that in this case indeed mu is
less than one oh three point five
because those two quantities are close
right I could do that the problem is
that this could go pretty wrong because
if any small then I know that xn bar is
not equal to MU I know that xn bar is
close to MU but also know that there's
pretty high chances that it's not equal
to mu in particular I know it's gonna be
somewhere at 1 over root and away from
you right 1 over root n being the root
and coming from what CLT right that's
the root and that comes from CLT CLT
tells us I mean you know in blunt words
CLT tells me I'm at the mean is at
distance 1 over root n from the
expectation pretty much
that's what it's telling so one of our
ooh then you know if I met if I met if I
have ten people in there one over root
10 is not a huge number right it's like
one-third pretty much okay so one-third
103.5 if the the true mean was actually
one of three point four but my average
was telling me it's one oh three point
four plus one-third I would actually
come to two different conclusions right
so we know that so let's say that mu is
equal to one over three point four okay
so that's you're not supposed to know
this right that's the truth
hidden truth okay now I have n is equal
to 10 so I know that X bar and minus one
or three point four is something of the
order of 1 over square root of 10 which
is of the order of say one point 0.3
okay okay so here this is all hand wavy
okay but that's what the central limit
theorem tells me what it means is that I
can have it is possible that X bar n is
actually equal to sorry one of three
point four is actually equal to 103
point four plus zero point three which
is equal to one over three point seven
which means that while the truth is that
mu is less than 103.5 then I would
conclude that mu is larger than 103.5
okay and that's because they have not
been very cautious okay so what we want
to do is to have a little buffer to
account for the fact that xn bar is not
a precise value for the
to Moo something that's 1 over root and
away from you and so what we want is the
better heuristic that says well if I
want to conclude that I'm less than 13.5
maybe I need to have one of less be less
than 1 a 3.5 - little buffer that goes
to 0 as my sample size goes to infinity
and actually that's what the law of
large number tells me but the central
limit theorem actually tells me that
this should be true something that goes
to 0 as n goes to infinity at the rate 1
over root n right that's basically what
the central limit theorem tells me so to
make this intuition more precise we need
to understand those fluctuations we need
to actually put in something that's more
precise than this like little Wiggles
here ok we need to actually have the
central limit theorem come in so here's
the example of comparing two groups so
pharmaceutical companies use apoptosis
testing to test if a drug is efficient
right that's what they do they want to
know does my new drug work and that's
what the Federal Drug Administration
officer is doing on the daily basis they
ask for extremely well regulated
clinical trials on thousand people and
check you know does this drug make a
difference it did everybody died does it
make no difference should people pay 200
bucks for a pill of sugar right so
that's what people are actually asking
so to do so of course there's no ground
truth about so there's actually sorry
there's a placebo effect so it's not
like actually giving a drug that does
not work is gonna have no effect on
patients it will have a small effect but
it's very hard to quantify we know that
it's there but we don't know what it is
and so rather than saying oh the ground
truth is no improvement the ground truth
is the placebo effect and we need to
measure what the placebo effect is all
right so what we're gonna do is we're
going to split our patients into two
groups and there's gonna be what's
called the test group and a control
group so the word test here is used in a
different way than I thought this is
testing so it will just
call it typically the drug group all
right and so I will refer to mute drug
in this for this guy okay so know this
let's say this is a cough syrup okay and
when you have a cough syrup what you
want to measure let's say well the way
you measure the efficacy of a drug seer
of a cough syrup is to number and
measure how many times you cough per
minute okay and so if I define you
control the number of expectations per
hour a per hour not let's say not first
a minute but per hour so I have just the
expected number right this is a number I
don't know because I don't have access
to the entire population of people will
ever take this cough syrup and so I will
call it new control for the control
group so those are the people have been
actually given just like sugar like
maple syrup and mute dragon those people
who are given the actual syrup okay and
you can imagine that maybe maple syrup
will have an effect on expectations per
hour just because well you know it's
just sweet and it helps okay and so we
don't know what this effect is gonna be
we just want to measure if the drug is
actually having just a better impact on
expectations per hour than the just pure
maple syrup okay so what we want to know
is if new drug is less than mu control
that would be enough if we had access to
all the populations that will ever take
the syrup for all ages then we would
just measure did this have an impact and
even if it's a slightly ever so small
impact then it's good to release this
cough syrup assuming that it has no side
effects or anything like this because
it's just better than maple syrup okay
the problem is that we don't have access
to this and we're gonna have to make
this decision based on samples that give
me imprecise knowledge about new drug
and new control so in this case and like
the first case where we compared in a
known expected value to a fixed number
which was 103.5 here we're just
comparing
two unknown numbers with each other okay
so there's two sources of randomness
trying to estimate the first one and
trying to estimate the second one okay
all right before I move on I just wanted
to tell you I apologize one of the
graders was not able to finish grading
his problem sets for today so for those
of you were here just to pick up their
homework feel free to leave now even if
you have a name tag it will pretend that
did not read it all right okay so I'm
sorry well you'll get it on Tuesday and
this will not happen again
all right so okay so for the clinical
trials now I'm gonna collect information
I'm gonna collect data from the control
group I'm gonna collect data from the
test group all right so my control group
here I don't have to collect the same
number of people in the control group
then in the drug group actually four
cups a rep maybe it's not that important
but you can imagine that if you think
you have the cure to a really annoying
disease it's actually hard to tell half
of the people you will get a pill of
nothing okay people tend to want to try
the drug they're desperate and so you
have to have this sort of imbalance
between who's getting the drug and who's
not getting the truck okay so it's not
and you know people have to qualify for
the clinical trials there's lots of
fluctuations that affect with the final
numbers of people who are actually gonna
get the drug and are gonna get the
control it's gonna be and so it's not
easy for you to make those two numbers
equal you'd like to have those numbers
equal if you can but not necessarily so
and by the way this is all part of some
statistical science called design of
experiments and in particular well you
know you can imagine that if one of the
series had higher variance you would
want to collect more people in this
group than the other group you yeah
yeah yeah that's on purpose and I'll
come to that in a second all right so
right to basically we're gonna make it
if your answer is is this true we're
gonna make it as hard as possible but no
harder for you to say yes to this answer
because what we'll see why okay so okay
so now we have two set of datas the X's
and the Y's the X's are the ones for the
drug and the Y's are the data that I
collected from the people who were just
given a placebo okay and so they're all
iid random variables in here since it's
a number of expectations I'm making a
you know blunt modeling assumption I'm
just gonna say it's pressed on one it's
characterized only by the mean new drug
or the mean mu control okay I've just
made an assumption here it could be
something different but let's say it's a
personal distribution so now what I want
to know is to test whether mu drug is
less than mu control we said that
already but the way we said it before
was not as mathematical as it is now now
we're actually making a test on the
parameters of question on distribution
whereas before or just making test on
like expected numbers okay so the
heuristic again if we try to apply the
heuristic now rather than comparing new
x-bar drug to some fixed number I'm
actually comparing X bar drug to some
control but now here I need to have
something that accounts for not only the
fluctuations of X bar drug but also for
the fluctuations of X bar control okay
and so now I need something that goes to
0 when all those two things go to
infinity and typically it should go to 0
with 1 over square root of and drug in 1
over square root of n control okay
that's what the central limit theorem
for both X bar drug and X bar control to
central limit theorems are actually
telling okay and then we can conclude
that this happens and as you said this
we're trying to make it a bit harder to
conclude this because let's face it if
we were actually using the simple
heuristic right so let's assume now that
we have for simplicity right so
let me assume that they have so I can
rewrite X bar drug less than X bar
control - this is something that goes to
zero I can write it as X bar drug minus
X bar control less than something
negative okay this is something okay so
now let's look at those guys this is the
difference of two random variables from
the central limit theorem this should be
approximately a Gaussian each and their
actually we're gonna think of them as
being independent right there's no
reason why the people in the control
group should have any effect on what's
happening to the people in the test
group those people probably don't even
know each other and so when I look at
this this should look like some me and
zero with some mean and some variance
that say I don't know what it is okay
the mean actually no it's new drug -
view control okay so if I were to plot
the PDF of this guy it would look like
this I would have something which is
centered at new drug - new control and
would look like this okay now let's say
that new drug is actually equal to MU
control that you know this
pharmaceutical company is a huge scam
and they really are trying to sell
bottle maple syrup bo corn syrup for
$200 a pop okay so this is a huge scam
and the truth things are actually equal
to zero so this thing is really centered
about zero okay now if we were not to do
this then basically half of the time I
would actually come up with a
distribution that's above this value and
a half of the time I would have
something that's below this value which
would mean that half of the scams would
actually go through FDA if I did not do
this so what I'm trying to do is to say
well okay you have to be here that
there's actually a very low probability
that just by chance you end up being
here okay and we'll make all this
statements extremely precise later
around but I think the drug thing
interesting to see why you're making it
hard because you don't want to allow
people to sell thing like that okay so
let's just before we go more into the
statistical thinking associated to test
let's just see how we would do this
quantification right I mean after all
this is what we've probably are the most
comfortable with at this point so let's
just make let's just try to understand
this and I'm gonna make the
statisticians favorite test which is the
thing that obviously you do at home all
the time every time you get a new
quarter is testing whether it's a fair
coin or not alright so this test of
course exists only in textbooks and and
I actually did not write this slide I
was lazy to just replace all this stuff
by the Cherry Blossom run so you have a
coin now you have 80 observations X 1 2
X 80 so n is equal to 80 I have X 1 X n
iid bernly P and I want to know if I
have a fair coin so in mathematical
language I want to know if P is equal to
1/2 and in this case it's kind of hard
to say sorry let's say this is just the
heads okay and a biased coin well you
know maybe you would potentially be
interested whether it's biased one
direction or the other but you know not
being a fair coin is already somewhat of
a discovery okay and so you just want to
know whether P is equal to one-half or P
is not equal to what happened okay now
if I were to apply the very naive first
example for to not reject the hypothesis
if I run this thing a hundred times 80
times I mean you need to see exactly 40
heads and 40 tails now this is very
unlikely to happen exactly okay you're
gonna have close to 40 heads and close
to 40 tails but how close should use
those things be okay and so the little
something is gonna be qualified by
exactly this okay so now here let's say
that my experiment gave me
fifty-four did I do well let's say heads
yeah
it's 54 yeah heads which means that my
xn bar is 54 over 80 which is point 68
all right all right so I have this this
estimator looks pretty large right it's
pretty it's much larger than 0.5 so it
does look like I mean my mom would
certainly conclude that this is a bias
going for sure because she thinks I'm
tricky all right so the question is can
this be due to chance right can this be
due to chance alone like what is the
likelihood that a fair coin would
actually end up being fifty four times
on heads rather than 40 okay and so what
we do is we say okay I need to
understand what is the distribution of
the number of times it comes on heads
and this is gonna be a binomial but it's
a little annoying to play with so we're
gonna use the central limit theorem that
tells me that xn bar minus P divided by
square root of P 1 minus P is
approximately distributed as an N 0 1
and here since n is equal to 80 I'm
pretty safe that this is actually gonna
work ok so now let's just be a little
more and I can actually use Slutsky here
and put xn bar here okay so let's key
tells me that this is okay to do alright
so now I'm actually going to compute
this so here I know this this is square
root of 80 this is 0.6 t 8 what is this
value here we'll talk about it well
we're trying to understand what happens
if it is a fair coin right so if fair
then P is equal to 0.5 right so what I
want to know is what is the likelihood
that a fair coin would give me point 68
let me finish alright so if what is the
likelihood
a fair coin will allow me to do this so
I'm actually allowed to plug in P to be
0.5 here and then your question is why
do I not plug in P to be 0.5 but you can
all right I just want to make you plug
in P at one specific point but you're
absolutely right
what you should you can look at is right
so okay let's forget about your question
for one second so now I'm gonna have to
look at xn bar minus 0.5 divided by xn
bar 1 minus xn bar then this thing is
approximately Gaussian and 0 1 if the
coin is fair otherwise I'm gonna have a
mean which is not zero here right if the
coin is something else whatever I get
here right so if my coin if let's just
write it for one second actually that's
let's let's answer your question first
it's actually gonna be easy I'm not sure
okay let's do it
so what is the distribution of this if P
so that's P is equal to one half point
five okay now if P is equal to 0.6 then
this thing is just well I know that this
is equal to square root of n X n bar
minus 0.6 divided by xn bar one minus xn
bar square root plus well now the
difference so square root of n 0.6 minus
0.5 divided by square root of xn bar 1
minus xn bar right now if P is equal to
0.6 then this guy is in 0 1 but this guy
is something different right this guy is
just a number that depends on square
root of n it's actually pretty large so
if I'm actually if I want to use the
that this guy has a normal distribution
I need to plug in the true value here
now the implicit question that I got was
the following says well if you know what
P is and what's actually true is also
this if P is equal to 0.5 then not only
since I know that root n xn bar minus P
divided by square root of P 1 minus P is
sum n 0 1 it's also true that square
root of n xn bar minus 0.5 divided by
square root of 0.5 1 minus 0.5 is n 0 1
right I know what P is I'm just gonna
make it appear okay and so what's
actually nice about this particular by
Bernoulli's experiments is that I can
check if my assumption is violated by
checking whether I'm actually so what
I'm gonna do right now is now to check
whether this is likely to be a Gaussian
or not right and there's two ways I can
violate it by violating the mean but
also by evaluating the variance and here
what I did in the first case I said well
I'm not allowing you to check whether
you violate the variance I'm just
plugging whatever variants are getting
whereas here I'm saying well there's two
ways you can violate it and I'm just
gonna factor everything in okay so now I
can plug in in this number so this is
square root so this is 80 this is point
68 so I can compute all this stuff I can
compute all this stuff here as well and
what I get in this case if I put the xn
bar 1 I get 3.45 okay and now I claim
that this makes it reasonable to reject
the hypothesis that P is equal to 0.5
can somebody tell me why
yeah three is pretty big so it's very
unlikely so right so this number that I
should see should look like the number I
would get if I asked a computer to draw
one random Gaussian for me right this
number when I draw one random Gaussian
is actually a number with 99.9% this
number will be between negative 3 and 3
but with 78% it's gonna be between
negative 2 & 2 ok so those are actually
between with 70% is basically 68% is
between minus 1 and 1 and with like 90%
is between minus 2 and 2 so getting of
3.45 when you do this is extremely
unlikely to happen which means that you
would have to be extremely unlucky for
this to ever happen now it can happen
right it could be the case that you flip
180 coins and 80 of them or heads with
what probability that this happen 1 over
2 to the 80 right which is probably
probably better off playing the lottery
with this kind of odds right I mean this
is just not gonna happen but it might
happen so we cannot remove completely
the uncertainty right it's still
possible that this is due to noise but
we're just trying to make all the cases
that are very unlikely go away ok and so
now I claim that 3.45 is very unlikely
for a Gaussian so if I were to draw the
PDF of a Gaussian of a standard Gaussian
right so n0 1 right so that's PDF of n 0
1 3.73 is basically here ok so it's just
like too far in the tails understood now
I cannot say that the probability that
the Gaussian is equal to 373 small right
I just cannot say that because it's 0
and it's also 0 for the probability that
it's 0 even though the most likely
values are around 0 right
is to continuous random variable so it's
it's gonna take any probability any
value give me it's gonna happen with
probability zero so what we're gonna say
is well the fluctuations are larger than
this number the probability that I get
anything worse than this is actually
extremely small right anything worse
than this is just like farther than 3.73
and this is gonna be what we control all
right so in this case I claim that it's
quite reasonable to reject the
hypothesis is everybody okay with this I
already find this shocking or everybody
has no idea what's going on there any
questions
yeah
that's correct and you're right you
should prefer so okay I didn't want to
plug in the pee everywhere but you
should plug in it everywhere you can
that's for sure
okay so let's agree on that and that's
true that it makes the number a little
bigger and you compute how much you
would get we would get if we put point
five there
wait a minute probably easy right well I
don't know what square root of 80 years
can somebody compute quickly what I'm
not asking you to do it but like what I
want is two times square root of 80
times point eighteen what three point
two two okay
I can make the same cartoon picture with
three point two two and I would be but
you're right this is definitely more
accurate and I should have done this I
didn't want to just get the confused
message okay all right so now here's the
second example that you can think of so
now I have 30 times I toss it 30 times
still in the realm of the central limit
theorem I get 13 heads rather than 15 so
I'm actually much closer to being
exactly at half so let's see if this is
actually gonna give me a plausible value
and what I get is that so I get point 33
in average if the true was 0.5 I would
get something like point 77 and now I
claim that point 77 is a plausible
realization for some standard Gaussian
okay
now point 77 is gonna look like it's
here and so that could very well be
something that just comes because of
randomness and again if you think about
it if I told you you were expecting 15
use of 13 you're happy to put that on
the account of randomness now of course
the question is going to be where do I
draw the line right
is 12 the right number is 11 is 10 what
is it and so we're gonna have what we're
gonna do so basically the answer is it's
whatever you want to be the problem it's
it's hard to think on the scale right
what does it mean to think of the scale
if I can think on this scale I'm gonna
have to think on the scale of 80 of them
I mean I have to think on the scale of
like running a hundred flip coin coin
flips and so this skill is moving it's a
moving target all the time every time
you have a new problem
you have to have a new skill in mind it
is very difficult the purpose of
statistical analysis and in particular
this process that content that takes
your x-bar and turns it into something
that should be standard Gaussian allows
you to map the value of x bar into a
scale that is the standard scale of the
Gaussian all right now all you need to
have in mind is what is a large number
or an unusually large number for a
Gaussian that's all you need to know
right so here by the way point seventy
seven is not this one because it was
actually negative point seventy seven so
the other one should show it this one
okay so I can be on the right or I can
be on the left but there are still
possible of zero but they are still
possible all right so understood like
you could actually have in mind all the
values that are plausible for a Gaussian
and those that are not plausible and
draw the line based on what you think is
a right number
so how large shoot a positive value of a
Gaussian to become unreasonable for you
is it 1 is it 1.5 is it to stop me when
I get there
the 2.5 the 3 what yeah so this is not
Bayesian statistics so there's no such
thing as a prior right now we'll get
there you'll have your moment during one
one short chapter
but the the right so there's no prior
here right it's really a matter of what
do you think is a Gaussian large or not
it's not a matter of coins it's not a
matter of anything now I've just reduced
it to just one question so forget about
everything we just said and I'm asking
you when do you decide that a Gaussian
is too large to be a reasonable number
is too large to be reasonably drawn from
a Gaussian and this number is 2 or 1.96
and that's basically the number that you
get from this quantum we've seen the
1.96 before right it's actually Q alpha
over 2 for alpha is equal to 5 percent
that's the quantile of a Gaussian so
actually what we do is we map it again
so we're not the gaussians and then we
map it again into some probabilities
which is the probability of being
farther than this thing and now
probabilities we can think probability
is something that quantifies my error
and the question is how what percentage
of error am I willing to tolerate and if
I tell you 5 percent that's something
you can really envision what it means is
that if I were to do this test a million
times 5 percent of the time I would
expose myself to making a mistake all
right that's all it would say if you
said well I don't want to account for 11
for 5% maybe I want 1% then you have to
move from 1.96 to 2.5 and then if you
say at one point or 1% then you have to
move to an even larger number so it
depends but stating this number 1% 5%
10% is much easier than stating these
numbers 1.96 2.5 etc so we're just
putting everything back on the scale all
right so here is to conclude this again
as we said does not suggest that the
point isn't fair now it might be that
the coin isn't fair we just don't have
enough evidence to say that and that
goes back to your question about why are
we siding with the fact that we're
making it harder to conclude that the
the runners were faster and this is the
same thing we're making it harder to
conclude that the coin is biased because
there is a status quo and we're trying
to see if we have evidence against the
status quo the status quo for the runner
they run they ran the same speed the
status quo for the coin can probably all
agree is that the coin is fair the
status quo for a drug I mean again
unless you prove me that you're actually
not a scammer is that you're actually
the status quo is that this is maple
syrup there's nothing in there why
wouldn't it new I mean if I let you get
away with it you would put maple syrup
just alright okay so now let's move on
to math all right so when I started
doing mathematics I'm gonna have to talk
about random variables and statistical
models and here there's actually a very
simple thing which is that it actually
goes back to this picture which is as
test is really asking me if I'm on one
side of if my if my parameter is in some
region of the parameter set or another
region of the parameter set right yes no
and so what I'm gonna be given is a
sample x1 xn I have a model and again
those can be braces depending on the day
and so now I'm gonna give myself data 1
and theta 2 a story theta 0 and theta 1
two disjoint subsets okay so I have my
right so capital theta here is the space
in which my parameter can live to make
two disjoint subsets I could just split
this guy in half right but I'm actually
gonna make myself I'm gonna say well
maybe it's this guy and this guy okay so
this is theta 0 and this is Theta 1 what
it means when I split those two guys I'm
actually in test I'm actually going to
focus only on theta 0 or theta 1 and so
it means that a priori I've already
removed all the possibilities of theta
being in this region what does it mean
this go back to the example of runners
this region here for the for the cherry
blossom run is the set of parameters
where mu was larger than 103.5
right we removed that we didn't even
consider this possibility we said either
it's Slice sorry that's mu equal to
103.5 and this was mu less than 1 over
3.5 okay but this guy's we're like it
happens it happens I'm not making any
statement about that case all right
so now I take those two subsets and now
I'm gonna give them two different names
because they're gonna have an asymmetric
role h0 is the null hypothesis and h1 is
the alternative hypothesis h0 is the
status quo h1 is what is considered
typically as scientific discovery so if
you're a regulator and you're gonna push
towards a zero if you're a scientist
you're gonna push towards h1 if you're
from a suitable company you're gonna
push towards s1 okay and so depending on
whether you want to be conservative oh I
can find evidence in a lot of data as
soon as you give me three data points
I'm gonna be able to find evidence that
means I'm gonna tend to say oh it's h1
but if you say I'll you need a lot of
data before you can actually move away
from the status quo that's h0 okay so
think of h0 as being status quo h1 being
some discovery that goes against the
status quo all right so if we believe
that the truth theta is either in one of
those what we say is we want to test h0
against h1 okay this is actually wording
so remember because this is how your
questions are going to be formulated and
this is how you want to probably
communicate as a statistician so you're
gonna say I have the null and I have an
alternative I want to test h0 against h1
I want to test the null hypothesis
against the alternative hypothesis okay
now the two hypotheses I forgot to say
are actually this h0 is that theta
belongs to theta 0 and h1 is that theta
belongs to theta 1 okay so here for
example theta was mu and that was mu
equal to 1 over 3.5 and this was mu less
then 103.5 okay
so typically they're not gonna look like
Thetas and things I did they're gonna
look like very simple things where you
take your usual notation for your usual
parameter and you just say in
mathematical terms what relationship
they should be satisfying right for
example in the drug example that would
be new drug is equal to mu control and
here that would be new drug is less than
you control right the number of
expectations is less than for people who
take the drug for the cough syrup is
less than the number of expectations of
people who take the corn syrup okay so
now what we want to do is so we've set
up our statistical hypothesis or we set
up our hypothesis testing problem sorry
you're a scientist you set up your
problem now what you're going to do is
collect data and what you're gonna try
to find on this data is evidence against
h0 and the alternative is gonna guide
you into which direction you should be
looking for evidence against this guy
all right and so of course the narrower
the alternative the easier it is for you
because you just have to look in one
possible candidate right but typically
you know each one is a big group like
less than nobody tells you it's either
one 0.1 of 103.5 or 103 people tell you
it's either 1 or 3.5 or less than 105
okay and so what we want to do is to
decide whether we reject h0 so we look
for evidence against h0 in the data okay
so as I said this guy's a zero and h1 do
not play symmetric role it's very
important to know which one you're gonna
place as h0 in which one you're gonna
place at h1 because you're gonna always
favor in case of sort of you know if
it's a close call you're always gonna
side with h0 okay so you have to be
careful about this you have to keep that
in mind that if it's a close call if
data does not have carry a lot of
evidence you're gonna side with h0 and
so
you're actually never saying that h0 is
true you're just saying I did not find
evidence against a Jiro so you don't say
I accepted a zero you say I failed to
reject h0 okay and so one of the thing
is that you want to keep in mind when
you're doing this is this innocent until
proven guilty so if you come from a
country like America there's such a
thing and in particular lack of evidence
does not mean that you are not guilty
right Oh Jay Simpson was found not
guilty it was not found innocent okay
and so this is basically what happens is
like you know the particular brings
their evidence and then you know the
jury has to decide whether they were
convinced that this person was a was
guilty of anything and the question is
do you have enough evidence but if you
don't have evidence it's not the burden
of the defender to prove that they're
innocent
nobody's proving they're innocent I mean
sometimes it helps but you just have to
make sure that there's not enough
evidence against you okay and that's
basically what it's doing your zero
until proven each one so how we're gonna
do this well as I said the role of
estimators in hypothesis testing is
played by something called tests and the
test is a statistic can somebody remind
me what a statistic is yeah yeah that's
actually just one step more so it's a
it's a function of the observations and
we require it to be measurable and as a
rule of thumb measurable means if I give
you data you can actually compute it
okay if you don't see a super an in for
you don't have to think about it all
right then so and so
oh yeah and so what we do is we just
have this test but now I'm actually
asking only from this guy this test a
yes/no answer which I can code as zero
one right so as a rule of thumb you say
that well the test is equal to 0 then a
0 the test is equal to 1 that h1 and as
we said is that if
test is equal to zero it doesn't mean
that is your is true it means that I
fail to reject h0 and if the test is
equal to 1 i reject h0 okay so i have
two possibilities i look at my data i
turn it into a yes/no answer and yes the
answer is really h 0 or H 1
okay which one is the most likely
basically alright so in the coin flip
example or test statistic
well our test statistic is actually
something that takes value 0 1 and
anything any function that takes value 0
1 is an indicator function ok so an
indicator function is just a function so
there's many ways you can write it but
I'm gonna so it's a one with a double
bar if you're uncomfortable with this
you're totally it's totally okay to
write I of something like I of a ok and
that's what so a here is a statement
like an inequality and equality some you
know mathematical statement okay we're
not mathematical I mean a can be you
know my grandma is 20 years old okay and
so this is basically one if a true and
zero if a is false okay that's the way
you want to think about it so just in
this function takes only two values and
that's it and basically it's just so
right so here here's the example that we
had we looked at whether the
standardized xn bar the one that
actually is approximately n 0 1 was
larger than something in absolute value
either very large or very small but
negative okay so we wanted to know if
I'm going back to this picture we wanted
to know if this guy was either to the
left of this of something or to the
right of something right was it in this
regions
now this thing here this indicator I can
view this as a function of X bar what it
does it really splits the possible
values of X bar which is just a real
number right in in two groups the groups
on which they lead to a value which is
one and the groups on which they lead to
a value which is zero right so what it
does is that I can actually think of it
as the real line X bar and there's
basically some values here where the
eval 1 may be I'm gonna get a 0 here
maybe I'm gonna get a 1 a 0 maybe I'm
gonna get a 1 I'm just splitting all
possible values of X bar and I see
whether they spit out upside which is 0
or which is 1 now in this case it's not
clear right I mean the function is very
nonlinear it's X bar minus 0.5 divided
by square root of X bar 1 minus X bar if
we put the P in the denominator that
would be clear that would just be
exactly something that looks like this
if X bar what the function would be like
this it would be 1 if it's smaller than
some value less than 0 if it's in
between two values and then 1 again all
right so that's sy okay so it starts at
so this is 1 right this is 1 and this is
0 so if X bar is too small or if X bar
is too large then I'm getting a value 1
but if it's somewhere in between them
getting a value 0 now if I have this
weird function it's not clear how this
happened okay I have a I mean right so
the picture here that I get is that I
have a weird nonlinear function all
right so that's X bar that's skirt of n
X bar and 0.5 divided by square root of
x bar and 1 minus X bar n right that's
this function a priori I have no idea
what this function looks like I mean
okay I can can probably analyze this
function but let's pretend we don't know
so it's like some crazy stuff like this
and all I'm asking is whether in
absolute value
it's either it's larger than C which
means that is this function larger than
C or less than minus C so the values on
which I'm going to say one the intake
the intervals on which I'm gonna say one
or this guy this guy this guy and this
guy okay and everybody else everywhere
else I'm saying zero everybody agrees
with this this is what I'm doing now of
course it's probably easier for you to
just package it into this nice thing
that's just either larger than C an
absolute value or less than C you don't
want to have to plot this function in
practice you don't have to now this is
where I'm actually claiming so here I
actually define to you a test and I
promise starting this lecture by saying
oh now we're gonna do something better
than computing averages now I'm telling
you well just computer an average and
the thing is the test is not just the
specification of this X bar it's also a
specification of this constant C alright
then the constant C was exactly were or
you know belief about what a large value
for a Gaussian is that's exactly where
it came in so this choice of C is
basically a threshold at which we decide
above this threshold this is unlikely to
come from a Gaussian below this
threshold we decide that it's likely to
come from a Gaussian so we have to
choose what this threshold is based on
what we think likely means all right so
just a little bit more of those of those
things so now we're gonna have to
characterize what makes a good test
right because think of well I'll come
back to it in a second
but you know you could have a test that
says reject all the time and that's
gonna be a bad test right the FDA is not
implementing a test that says yes all
drugs work
let's just go to Aruba okay so like
people are trying to have something that
tried to works all the time
now FDA is Donnell either saying let's
just say that no drugs work and let's go
to
alright they just try to say the right
thing as often as possible and so we're
gonna have to measure this so the things
that are associated to attest that the
rejection region and if you look at this
X in EN such that Phi of X is equal to 1
this is exactly this guy that I drew the
values of the sample so here I
summarized the values of the sample into
their average but the values of the
sample that I collect that we will lead
to a test that says 1 alright so this is
the rejection region if I collect the
data point technically I have right so I
have e to the N which is a big space
like this all right so that's e to the N
think of it as being the space of X n
bars and I have a function that takes
only value 0 or 1 so I can decompose it
into this part where it takes value 0
and the part where it takes value 1 and
those can be super complicated right
can I have things like this I can have
some weird little islands where it takes
value 1 I can have some islands where it
takes value 0 I can have some weird
stuff going on but I can always
partition it into the value where it
takes value 0 in the value where it
takes value 1 and the value where it
takes 1 if this is if Phi is equal to 1
this is called the rejection region of
supply okay so that's just this the
samples that would lead me to rejecting
and notice that this is the indicator of
the rejection region alright the test is
the indicator of the rejection region so
there's two ways you can make an error
when there's a test either the truth is
in h0 and you're saying
actually it's h1 or the truth within h1
and you say it's h0 and that's how we
building the asymmetry between H 0 and H
1 is that we control only one of the two
errors and we hope for the best for the
second one so the type 1 error is the
one that says well if it is actually the
status quo but I claim that there's a
discovery if it's actually a zero but I
claim that
in each one that I meet I commit a type
1 error okay and so the probability of
type 1 error is this function alpha of
sigh which is just the probability of
saying that psy is equal to 1 when theta
is in h0 now the problem is that this is
not just number because theta is just
like moving all over H 0 right there's
many values that theta can be right so
theta is somewhere here so right so for
simplicity we're gonna think of theta as
being new and 103.5 okay and so I know
that this is theta 1 and this was just
this point here was theta 0 okay agreed
this is with the cherry blossom run now
here in this case it's actually easy my
function I need to compute this function
alpha psi which is maps theta in theta 0
to P theta of sine equals 1 so that's
the probability that I reject when theta
is in h0 then there's only one of them
to compute because theta can only take
this one value so this is really 103.5
okay so that's the probability that
reject when the true mean was 103.5 now
if I was testing whether if h0 was this
entire guy here all the values larger
than 103.5 then i would have to compute
this valve this function for all
possible values of theta in there and
guess what the worst case is when it's
going to be here because it's so close
to the alternative that it's that's
where I'm making the most error possible
and then there's the type 2 error which
is defined basically in the you know
symmetric way is the function that map's
theta to the probability so that's the
probability of type 2 errors the
probability that I fail to reject a zero
rights I is equal to 0 I fail to reject
h0
but that's where theta actually came
from h1 okay so in this example that's
clear if I'm here like if the true mean
was 100 I'm looking at the probability
that's the true mean is actually 100 and
I'm actually saying it was one of three
point five where it's not less than what
well it's just
it means it's a function that map's
theta zero to R you've seen functions
right okay so that's just the way you
write so you typically write something
like so that means that's a function f
that goes from say R to R and that map's
X to x squared
okay so here I'm just saying I don't
have to consider all possible values I'm
only considering the values on theta 0
the value that it takes I put R actually
it could restrict myself to the interval
0 1 because those are probabilities so
it's just telling me where my function
comes from and where my function goes to
and beta is a function right so beat up
side of theta is just the probability
that theta is sine theta that theta is
equal to 1 and I could define that for
all Thetas sorry that's AI is equal to 0
in this case and I could define that for
all Thetas but the only ones that lead
to an error are the Thetas that are in
h1 otherwise that I mean I can define
this function it's just not gonna
correspond to an error okay and the
power of a test is the smallest so the
power is basically 1 minus an error 1
minus the probability of an error so
it's the probability of making a correct
decision okay
so it's the probability of making a
correct decision under h1 that's what
the power is but again this could be a
function right because there's many ways
that can be in a 24h one is an entire
set of numbers for example all the
numbers that are less than 103.5 and so
what I'm doing here when I define the
power of a test I'm looking at the
smallest possible of those
values okay so I'm looking at this
function one - okay so maybe I should
actually expand a little more on this
[Applause]
okay so beta side of theta is the
probability under theta that sy is equal
to zero right that's the probability for
theta in each one in a serine in the
theta 1 which means under the
alternative that I fail to reject and I
really should because theta was actually
in theta 1 okay so this thing here is
the probability of type 2 error now this
is 1 minus the probability that I did
reject it and I should have rejected hey
that's just a little off the compliment
because if sy is not equal to 0 then
it's equal to 1 so now if I rearrange
this it tells me that the probability
that Y is equal to 1 this is actually 1
- beat up sy of theta okay so that's
true for all theta sin theta 1 and what
I'm saying is well so this is now a good
thing right this number being large is a
good thing it means I should have
rejected and I rejected I want this to
happen with large probability and so
what I'm going to look at this the most
conservative choice of this number right
well then being super optimistic and say
oh but indeed if theta was actually
equal to 0 then I'm always going to
conclude that I mean if mu is equal to 0
everybody runs in 0 seconds then I
should definitely with high probability
I'm actually again I'm gonna make no
mistake but really I should look at the
worst possible case ok so what I'm
looking at is basically the smallest
value it can take point
thena one is called
power up sigh power of the test subside
okay so that's the smallest possible
value it can take alright so I'm sorry
this is a lot of definitions that you
have to sink in and it's not super
Pleasant but that's what testing is
there's a lot of jargon those are
actually fairly simple things just maybe
you should like get a sheet for yourself
and say these are the new terms that I
learned what is their toss test
rejection region probably have type 1
error probability of type 2 error and
power and just make sure you know what
those guys oh and null and alternative
hypothesis okay and once you know all
these things you know what I'm talking
about you know what I'm referring to and
this is just jargon but in the end those
are just probabilities and I mean
there's are natural quantities just for
some reason people have been used to
using different terminology so just to
illustrate what type when do I make a
type 1 error and when do I not make a
type 1 error so I make a type 1 error if
h0 is true and I reject h0
right so the off there you know blocks
or when I make an error when the when
I'm on the diagonal terms h1 is true and
I reject h0 that's a correct decision
when h0 is true and i fail to reject h0
that's also the correct decision to make
so I only make this is errors when I'm
in one of the green box I'm sorry in the
red blocks and one block is the trivial
is the type 1 error and one other block
is the type 2 here that's all it means
okay so you just have to know which one
we call the one I mean we could have
this of course was pretty pretty I mean
this was chosen in a pretty ad-hoc way
so to conclude this lecture let me ask
you a few questions
if in a US Court the defendant is found
either say let's just say for the sake
of discussion innocent or guilty all
right it's really guilty or not guilty
but let's say innocent or guilty okay
when does the jury make it a type 1
error
yeah
and it's guilty and it's innocent right
the status quo
everybody is innocent until proven
guilty so that's our h0 is that the
person is innocent and so that means
that H zero is innocent and so we're
looking at the probability of type 1
errors that's when we reject the fact
that it's innocent so we include that
this person is guilty okay so type 1
error is when this person is innocent
and we conclude is guilty what is the
type 2 error letting a guilty person go
3 which actually according to
Constitution is the better of the two
all right so what we're going to try to
do is to control the first one and hope
for the best for the second one how
could the jury make sure that they make
know type 1 error ever I'll always let
the guy go free right what is the effect
on the type 2 error yeah it's the worst
possible right I mean basically for
every guy that's guilty you let them go
that's the worst you could do okay and
same thing right how can the jury make
sure that there's no type 2 error
I always convict what is the effect on
the American budget what is the effect
on the type 1 error right so the effect
is that basically the type 1 error is
maximized so there's this trade-off
between type 1 and type 2 error that's
inherent and that's why we have this
sort of multi objective thing we're
trying to minimize two things at the
same time and I can't find many ad hoc
ways right so if you've taken any
optimization I'm not trying to optimize
two things when one is going up while
the other one is going down the only
thing you can do is make ad hoc
heuristics maybe you try to minimize the
sum of those two guys maybe you try to
minimize one third of the third guy the
first guy plus 2/3 of the second guy
maybe you try to minimize the first guy
plus the square of the second guy you
can think of many ways but none of them
is more justified than the other
however for statistical hypothesis
testing there's one that's very well
just to find it which is just constrain
your type 1 error to be the smallest to
be at a level that you find you deem
acceptable 5% I want to
let go of at most 5% sorry I want to
convict at most 5% of innocent people
that's what I deem reasonable and based
on that I'm gonna try to convict as many
people as they can all right so that's
the called the neyman-pearson paradigm
and we'll talk about it next time all
right thank you